est ce que la ministre la condition
féminine peut se lever regarder droit
dans les yeux les femmes et les jeunes
filles qui seront éventuellement touchés
par ce projet de loi et leur dire avec
la même indifférence que son premier
ministre qu'il y à d'autres emplois de
disponible ça vise autant les femmes que
les hommes c'est le port de signes
religieux qui interdit les un consensus
au québec pour aller de l'avant la tue
ça fait depuis 2000 presse que la
position de la cac et l'économie alors
ce projet de loi sur la laïcité est il
raisonnable nécessaire ou va-t-il trop
loin comme le laisse entendre des
opposants hier on s'est entretenu avec
le sociologue gérard bouchard qui a
signé le rapport de la commission de
consultation sur les accommodements avec
charles est le monsieur bouchard défend
toujours le consensus établi alors sur
l'interdiction du port des signes
religieux sur les personnes en autorité
une autorité de coercition monsieur
telus le dénonce
alors ce soir nous nous accueillons
madame julie latour l'état avocate
membre des juristes pour la laïcité
féministes qui a signé au fil des années
plusieurs textes plaidant pour la
laïcité elle défend le projet de loi
elle est aussi l'ancien bâtonnière de
montréal
elle a été membre du ca du conseil du
statut de la femme madame latour bonsoir
bonsoir alors alors bien d'être avec
nous à votre réaction à toutes ces
réactions que l'on entend depuis cette
fameuse déclaration du maire stang bird
et qui est parfois dénoncé par la classe
politique mais qu'en fait le maire
réaffirme mais la déclaration du maire
steinberg
d'une part ce qui est ce qui est fort
inquiétant c'est qu'on remarque des
clips qui la prononce à partir d'un
écrit alors c'est pas quelque chose qui
est arrivée spontanément l'oci mûrement
réfléchie de faire une affirmation qui
est aussi éhontée par rapport à la
nature du projet de loi
et si le maire steinberg prêche pour
l'ouverture et là tolérance certainement
c'est le contraire dont il fait preuve
et là on voit que unanimement d'une
certaine manière ça me réconforte de
voir que tant le premier ministre du
canada justin trudeau le premier
ministre
du québec et nombre d'autres y l'ue
condamne ce qui est une exagération sans
bornes par rapport aux enjeux véritables
du débat et pourquoi vous le défendez ce
projet de loi qui faut-il le rappeler
soulève beaucoup d'opposition dans
certains milieux manif la semaine
dernière il y en aura d'autres dimanche
y compris par des femmes juristes
pourquoi vous le défendez ce projet de
liste un projet de loi qui est très
important que l'on attend de longue date
qui par son libellé le projet de loi 21
il est à la fois sobre et substantif
modéré et efficace et il est le reflet
d'un état mature qui agit pour préserver
le bien commun et qui est
l'aboutissement d'un long processus
alors c'est vraiment nécessaire c'est
c'est le rôle de l'état de d'équilibré
de procéder à une mise en équilibre
entre les différents droits fondamentaux
et c'est ce qui est fait en instance et
vous savez si le maire ce tie break sera
en israël il pourrait peut-être
s'entretenir avec l'ancien juge en chef
de la cour suprême d'israël à rabat rac
que je pense pas qu'on puisse le
qualifier de racistes ou xénophobes qui
a développé une intéressante une
importante et orrit en droit
constitutionnel qui dit justement qui
est une différence entre la portée
constitutionnelle d'un droit comment il
est affirmé dans la charte et comment
ont pu le restreint dans une loi est-ce
que vos dires il est quand même étonnant
jeu pas de quoi qu'on sorte de notre
projet de loi issu prononcerait l'on va
rester au québec
mais ce qui serait allé pointer
religieux est ce que je me trompe mais
c'est au delà
oui mais mais c'est que cette théorie et
s'applique à d'accord à tous en fête à
toutes les chartes des droits et elle
dit que cette mise en équilibre elle est
très important entre eux le droit pur
parce qu'on aspire et le droit
fondamental qu'elle tel pays est
appliquée alors je vous êtes que les
modérés le projet de loi je faire
entendre gérard bouchard hier parce que
le procédé de notre vue quand c'est des
pour et des contres et de soumettre
alain les arguments contre et avec vous
ce soir je vous soumets les autres
arguments dans une perspective
d'équilibré évidemment alors on va
coûter gérard bouchard hier pour qui ce
projet de loi est plutôt radical on
l'écouté ce projet d'une certaine
manière me paraît radicale d'une chambre
qu'au québec on n'est pas une société
comme
c'est une société qui soucieuses
compromis de débats de sans plomb les
plus sensibles que ça c'est contraire à
notre culture politique
alors monsieur bouchard donc des noms ce
projet de loi là et parmi ceux qui
dénoncent le projet de loi au delà du
consensus de monsieur mouche arles
certains universitaires qui ont signé un
texte disait ça valide des préjugés que
c'est un projet discriminatoire
déjà qu'ils sont allés beaucoup plus
loin et on dit en manifestation dimanche
que c'était vraiment xénophobes
islamophobes et antisémites
moi je suis très soucieuse des droits et
libertés et c'est pourquoi je milite
pour la laïcité
et qu'est-ce que si la laïcité c'est le
fait que grâce à ce projet de loi on va
clarifier les eaux sulfureuses que
mentionnait gérard bouchard parce que le
avec l'avènement des sociétés
pluralistes
la laïcité c'est le socle d'un état
pluraliste qui permet à toutes les
convictions religieuses et à la liberté
de conscience de s'exprimer et donc dans
nos démocraties modernes et ses récents
dans l'histoire l'état doit accepter le
pluralisme religieux mais réciproquement
le religieux doit s'ouvrir à l'altérité
et nos chartes des droits d'ailleurs qui
sont invoquées c'est cet idéal
rationnelle laïque et donc c'est le
socle de la liberté de conduire de
conscience et de religion et c'est très
important
la cour suprême du canada elle même a
dit que la neutralité de l'état c'est un
impératif démocratique et elle soulevé
le fait qu' il n'existe pas de
définition de la neutralité religieuse
de l'état ni dans la charte québécoise
ni dans la charte canadienne dans le
dossier sur la prière au saguenay et
dans une décision qui a été rendue il y
a dix jours telus communications la cour
suprême a dit elle-même le choix des
politiques dans une démocratie
parlementaire demeure la responsabilité
des législateurs et non celles des
tribunaux alors si ce que le
gouvernement fait ouais alors voirie
revenir à ce que le gouvernement fait
notamment parlé de la clause dérogatoire
et
et le fait qu'il adopte maintenant ce
projet de loi est basé sur un principe
discriminatoire qui le profilage des
individus sur la base de la religion ces
gens là disent écoutez l'état oui peut
être non mais les individus ce ne sont
pas l'état alors elle est là le décalage
en fait dans des perceptions des nma il
ya deux points principaux projets de loi
d'une part d'affirmer la laïcité de
l'état et ses principes fondateurs et
ensuite cette exigence alors le les
tribunaux la cour suprême elle-même a
dit que la neutralité de l'état devait
être rayé les apparentes et que l'état
s'incarne dans ses représentants qui s'y
lorsqu il professe adopte ou favorise
une religion au détriment d'une autre
porte fonds entorse alors c'est très
noble devrait pour l'état dans une
société qui pluraliste vous savez dans
lorsqu'on y croyant on croit à plus
grand que soi dieu
lorsqu'on est citoyen a fortiori quand
on oeuvre pour l'état on doit croire à
plus grand que soi qui est le bien
commun évidemment le consensus se
bouchant télé c'était les personnes en
autorité de coercition on doit s'arrêter
pour la pause mais après on va voir
réagir à ce que madame de la ville
d'yzeure l'assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui la question pourquoi donc
inclure maintenant les enseignants ce
qui est vu comme une mesure d'exclusion
par les opposants restés avec nous on
poursuit la conversation entre et la
peau
[Musique]
mon invité ce soir et la juriste julie
latour qui défend le projet de loi qui
le trouve essentiel de la tour avant la
pause on se lançait la question pourquoi
les enseignants
hier on avait monsieur bouchard qu'ils
défendent est encore son consensus qui
constate le projet loi est radical
mais pourquoi les enseignants en quoi il
existe une autorité
les enseignants d'une part le québec
ayant déconfessionnaliser ces
commissions scolaires alors les
québécois ont collectivement renoncer à
des droits constitutionnels d'avoir une
éducation publique chrétiennes
catholique protestante et que le visage
de soit neutre vous savez albert camus
l'écrivain disait l'école doit être le
lieu où l'on enseigne que le savoir
universel partagé par tous ce qui n'est
pas le cas du religieux et un professeur
ne peut pas arriver en classe
aujourd'hui avec un chandail dieu
n'existe pas alors la réciproque de
cette autorité
elle est celle d'ouvrir à la liberté
aussi parce que c'est le rôle de l'état
de nous permettre de nous émanciper de
notre famille et de notre communauté et
coutances comme charlot déjà là depuis
hier on entend souvent à propos des
hidjabs on entend dire que les femmes
qui le portent font du prosélytisme
auprès des élèves que le seul fait de
porter le hidjab est une forme
d'endoctrinement que le port du hidjab
et d autres signes religieux peut
traumatiser les élèves
mais rien de tout cela n'a été prouvée
et à ma connaissance il n'est même
jamais eu d'études qui ont été faites
pour appuyer des aspersions comme celle
là qu est monsieur barrette je
l'aimerais ton le vu affluer ce n'est
par les journalistes aujourd'hui en
début d'émission le canton insisté là
dessus les gens nés les 120 sauve un
petit peu alors gérard bouchard a
reconnu lors de votre entretien que pour
les juges et les policiers c'est un
nécessaire cette neutralité pour la
confiance
si le même principe qui s'applique vous
dirais que l'étude s'appelle le bon sens
c'est la neutralité réel est apparent
qui est déjà établie par les tribunaux
mais j'étais également extrêmement
étonné d'entendre gérard bouchard dire
qu'il ne voyait pas d'objectif urgent et
et elle au projet de loi alors que c'est
lui même
j'avais l'impression de rêver qui a
coprésidé la commission créée en 2007
qui a sillonné le québec qui a coûté des
millions qui a tenu des audiences
partout à travers le québec était une
commission nationale
alors pourquoi at il accepté s'il n'y
voyait pas un enjeu et parlant de bouche
heurter leur jeu j'aimerais aussi
mentionné dans le cas de charles terreur
qui que l'on voit partout et qui s'érige
comme parangon de vertu c'est étonnant
que l'on entende pas davantage le fait
que peu de temps avant la comme le début
des audiences de la commission
il a reçu à titre personnel la bourse
templeton de 1.5 millions de dollars us
une bourse qui remercie cette fondation
sert à dissimuler le fait religieux dans
le monde
à mon sens alors d'une part vous avez
dans les cours d'anglais on apprenait my
taylor is rich et résister à le dire
mais je vais arrêter leur job oui vous
donné par cellule et de la commission ça
s'agite sur les travaux je pense que
c'est un élément qui est extrêmement
important et revenons quand même au
projet de loi c'est ça qui est encore
jeté le et est un philosophe il l'a reçu
cette bourse vous en parler publiquement
mais revenons d'abord ils renient
maintenant de toute façon le consensus
sur la question des personnes en
autorité de coercition ce que les gens
disent en fait c'est qu'ils ont un
pouvoir de coercition on prive les gens
de liberté un enseignant de prive
personne de liberté alors est ce que le
gouvernement a le fardeau de la preuve
là dessus mais la liberté intellectuelle
c'est une liberté la liberté d'apprendre
la liberté de pouvoir devenir ce qu'ils
on veut être dans la vie et surtout je
répète là l'interdiction des sites des
signes religieux
c'est une exigence c'est le corollaire
de la liberté de religion et de
conscience parce que l'iss
la religion n'est pas inné comme
l'appartenance ethnique ou et tous les
citoyens doivent pouvoir se reconnaître
dans l'état et chaque état selon sa
trajectoire historique
ici il ya eu beaucoup de cheminement qui
ont été faits par tous les québécois
parlant de la clause dérogatoire
dispositions que le gouvernement a
choisi d'adopter ou d'inclure
maintenant dans son projet de loi avant
même que ne soit contestée devant les
tribunaux
les nouvelles restrictions par exemple
l'interdiction du port de signes
religieux puis aussi cette clause
grand-père qui certains disent bien que
sacré de classe d'enseignants alors
cette clause dérogatoire
elle prive les citoyens de tout recours
devant les tribunaux et en cela les gens
disent que c'est complètement illégitime
de faire de l'adopter la clause
dérogatoire fait partie intégrante de la
charte des droits et libertés et de la
charte canadienne dans les deux cas
suite à des négociations qui ont alors
il n'y a pas d'article honni ou autre et
jean chrétien lui même qui était
ministre de la justice à l'époque dans
une conférence en 2012 pour les 35 ans
de la charte canadienne disait la charte
canadienne pourquoi elle est vue comme
un modèle dans le monde parce qu'elle
est le résultat d'un équilibre parfait
entre le pouvoir politique et judiciaire
et douvier cet équilibre de la clause
dérogatoire
alors elle est le fait que certains
opposants disent n'y a pas de problèmes
concrets à régler mais pas de problème
réel les pas d'urgence à régler
maintenant en adoptant cette clause là
est ce que le gouvernement n'a pas ici
encore une fois le fardeau de la preuve
mais le but de la clause dérogatoire en
instance après 12 en 2d boy de réflexion
c'est que nous ayons une paix sociale
d'abord et avant tout de mettre un terme
aux hostilités d'avancer ensemble vers
un avenir collectif partagé et ensuite
le gouvernement se soumet à l'électorat
c'est absolument démocratique et je
pense que cette question aussi tout le
projet de loi 21 pose l'enjeu de quel
canada nous voulons et comment nous
pouvons avancer ensemble avec nos
différences puisque si le canada prêche
tellement pour la diversité pourquoi
n'accepte t-il pastel du québec dans les
manfestations dimanche on entendait des
femmes dire que ce projet de loi mettait
en danger la vie des musulmanes que dans
l'essai laisser les femmes ne pourrais
plus travailler
que répondez vous à ça mais c'est un
code vestimentaire alors comme vous
savez nombre de corps d'emploi visés
portent déjà un uniforme tout est dans
le mot uniforme
alors là on ajoute au code vestimentaire
on n'exclut personne c'est les
conditions mais nos droits et libertés
ne sont pas absolues et surtout une
feinte sociétal qui est d'avoir un état
qui ait véritablement ne de sorte que la
liberté de conscience de tous et de
religions soient protégés vous avez
entendu madame david peut-être en
express ça se passe à l'assemblée
nationale regarder dans les yeux
dire à quelqu'un qu'elle ne pourrait pas
avoir d'emploi et donc ce projet de loi
est un projet d'exclusion c'est un
projet de loi qui au contraire va nous
donner des balises et va nous permettre
de c'est un instrument de prévisibilité
parce que je le redis là il ya une
fraternité citoyenne quand on vit en
société et c'est cette prestation là et
là toutes les religions sont égales par
rapport à la laïcité
et vous savez s'ouvrir on parle de
s'ouvrir à la diversité mais c'est à
chacun de la fin et on a une diversité
pas juste entre les individus mais en
soi même mais s'il y avait ici une
étudiante au bac en pédagogie qui
portent le voile qui ne pourrait pas
travailler avec ce projet de loi là que
lui diriez-vous parce qu'elle serait ce
sera victime de discrimination elle se
sent exclue elle se sent mise à l'écart
par la société je lui dirais que c'est
très noble
la fonction qu'elle aura parce qu'elle
sera la dépositaire de l'aspiration à
l'égalité de tous les citoyens alors
personne n'est exclu et la laïcité se
bâtissent et elle pendant qu'un élève
sur trois y mai de 9 heures à 5 heures
vous savez la foi ne se prouve pas elle
s'éprouve mais la nature merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous on sait très bien
mais 4,60 qu'on aura d'autres occasions
de sans parler de tous les points de vue
sur ce projet de loi qu'il faut bien le
reconnaître en flammes actuellement
l'épargné nous fait avancer comme ceux
de roue et même base de parler de paix
sociale mais elle est un peu perturbé le
nom mais ensuite vous savez c'est comme
les grands débats de société peine de
mort avortement mais la steel le débat
d'une société pluraliste qui veut
avancer
merci beaucoup mon âme l'a toujours
merci au revoir sur moi